- People are the ROI of life.
(lighthearted music)
I couldn't believe more
in the people aspect
of all of this.
There's nothing you learn from any,
I don't give a
how hands-on or how much
you actually have done.
None of it is even remotely close
to its ROI positive business,
like the people you meet.
The skills are commoditized.
There's a lot of people
that are gonna be able to do what you do.
It might be tough at a young age,
it's tough at an older age.
Like you may not be extroverted,
it might feel weird to say hello.
But like in your last
week or what have you
as much cafeteria time,
as much like, hello.
As much as you can muster
up, literally hi, um.
I believe in it the most.
The hi, um in the elevator
couldn't push you more.
If you get anything out of
this, like that one random hello
that this musters out, could
literally be the whole thing.
Just could, just is.
Actually I think that's
my advice and we talked
about this a little bit
in the VaynerSports stuff,
like that's my advice for
when you go back to school.
Probably my favorite talk I've given
in the last couple years was
to the USC football team.
I speak a lot, I do this a lot,
and you can always tell
when you hit a nerve.
There's a moment in that USC
football talk where I tell them
I'm like, you guys are idiots.
You think you're so cool
cause you're on the USC football team?
Meanwhile, 99% of you, this
is the highlight of your life.
Straight up, for 90% of you,
this is the greatest year
of your life, right now.
That's just the truth.
You can be mad at me,
you can be sad at me,
you can think I'm stupid.
Tell you straight to your faces,
for 80, 90% of you this is it.
This is the pinnacle,
so you better squeeze
the out of this thing.
Like what, you're too cool for somebody?
You gotta listen to your
headphones and put your hoodie on?
You can't say hello?
Like I'm desperate for the
guy that's thinking that
to just say, yo you need
to go the other way.
And you think you're too cool
and you're puttin' your Beats
by Dre on and your hoodie
and not looking anybody in the eye
and think you're somebody?
And your life's gonna
suck for the next 50 years
cause you didn't say hello to
the kid sitting next to you
who went on to run Disney.
To me, the ROI of things
like college are the people.
People are the game in life.
That's how life actually plays out.
That is the best piece
of advice I can give you.
Like when you go back to
school, say hello to everybody.
People are the ROI of life.
So, it's cool that you
got better at analytics
or like real life experience
of talking to a client.
Commodity, you would've
gotten that some point anyway.
Whether you can do it or not, cool.
But like actually becoming
friends with each other in here,
like actually, not like
when the Slack channel dies,
everybody in here can help
the other person potentially
in a real significant way, you know?
80% of you, 'specially if you
don't get into this company,
are gonna have jobs you
hate right outta school
and the other person's gonna
have something they like
and they could be the
one recommending you in.
People.
Questions?